in fact 22 million households report not
having the ability to pay next month's
rent and millions will be faced with
evictions for past months missed
payments unless Congress acts this is a
potential catastrophe and that's why
Senate Democrats including Senator
Warren and van Holland and Senator Brown
who's been leading the effort but
couldn't be with us today but his
leading efforts on the Senate floor on
this issue tomorrow and our other
leaders on the Banking Committee and
elsewhere have introduced bills that
would provide an extension of the
protections and the rental assistance
necessary to keep people in their homes
you throw someone out of their home
their whole life gets disrupted their
health care their health gets worse
their job opportunities get worse their
kids educational abilities get worse
housing is fundamental and it has ripped
ripped who've been ripped by this kovat
crisis now leader McConnell and Senate
Republicans have in blocked introduction
of our bills refusing to act on the
house-passed hero's bill passed more
than two months ago and they assisted
only on a three-month pause while they
quote assess the conditions in the
country and that's their words well
their differing and delay has brought us
to this moment we're about to see these
critical protections expire if they
haven't dithered if they had sat down
with us speaker Pelosi and I sent
McConnell a letter three weeks ago and
let said let's tit darn him let's start
sitting to sit down and talking we
wouldn't be here we already had an
affordable housing crisis that
disproportionately effected black and
brown families before the global
pandemic forced people out of work and
leader McConnell wants to say how he's
gonna watch how this plays out well it
seems that Senate Republicans have
finally felt the heat and now they're
saying we should do another bill in the
next few weeks but after months of
waiting Senate Republicans can't even
agree on a plan
they're in total disarray in conflict
with each other and the administration
on a path forward one of the priorities
Republicans do seem to agree on is what
leader McConnell
has been clamouring about for weeks that
protecting corporations is their number
one priority
one in five renters facing eviction and
McConnell cants the talks stopped
talking about the pandemic of lawsuits
we're having an a looming eviction
crisis and by all accounts Republicans
are preparing a bill that won't keep
families in their homes
we know evictions and unpaid bills can
have serious and long-term effects on
households and more than 40% of black
and latin x renters report their unlined
unlikely to make the rent in the next
pay period getting evicted can cause
damage to a family's finances and
eviction records take years to repair
without rental assistance more people
will experience housing instability or
homelessness putting their health and
everything else at risk what am i
Crowley's my Republican colleagues have
to say to these individuals you lose
your job through no fault of your own
this crisis you're about to be evicted
from your house again through no fault
of their of your own
what does McConnell say I want to help
the corporate big boys on K Street
bye-bye we don't need you
awful many of the people out of the
other I'm always ahead of what my staff
write so not always sometimes if we if
we pass emergency rental assistance and
extend the evictions moratorium we'd
help families and individuals pay the
bills stay in their homes stabilize the
rental market and keep up help owners
keep up with their property taxes and
mortgages so once again I say to leader
McConnell to Senate Republicans work
with us to get something done begin
bipartisan talks it's the only way to
pass a bill and to provide people the
help they desperately need Senate
Democrats will not stop fighting senator
Warren
so I want to start by thanking our
leader who has been instrumental in
trying to put together help for families
that are struggling and Senator Van
Hollen we've worked together because we
are just days away from a housing crisis
that could be prevented if Mitch
McConnell stops stalling and the Senate
acts this is about our health our
economy and our values forcing thousands
of people out of their homes during a
pandemic will make a public health
crisis worse widespread housing
disruptions will also affect essential
workers and others who are keeping our
economy going and a wave of evictions
will hit communities of color the
hardest further deepening racial
inequities in our nation so first how
bad is this problem more than 30% of all
renters say today that they have little
or no confidence they can make more than
40% of black and Latin X renters aren't
sure they'll be able to make their next
rent payment nearly two-thirds of
renters who are not confident about
making their rent earn less than $35,000
a year and more than a quarter of black
and Latin X renters couldn't pay last
month's rent or had it deferred think
about that that's one in every four
black or Latino renters who are already
behind on their rent and to add to that
the high unemployment rate the number of
workers across the country who have had
their hours and income cut and the
number of small businesses that have
shuttered and may never reopen and it's
clear that the number of evictions will
continue to rise experts are predicting
an avalanche of evictions if we don't
institute new protections we are already
seeing a rise in evictions in cities
where local eviction bans have lapsed
this is a crisis we can avoid instead of
further delay and denial the Senate can
step up now and prevent this catastrophe
before millions of people are forced out
of their homes
representative Chuy Garcia and I
introduced the protecting renters from
evictions and fees Act this bill
protects renters from losing their
housing if they lose their job or have
their hours cut during this crisis and
can't make their housing payment the
bill extends the federal eviction
moratorium to last one year instead of
expiring this week that means that
renters would be protected until March
of 2021 it also makes the moratorium
Universal every renter will be protected
and every renter will know that they are
protected that's really important
because right now
renters often don't know if they're
covered by the federal moratorium and
they are still getting evicted our bill
also makes sure that renters don't get
hit with high fees or penalties if they
need a few extra months to pay the rent
we also need senator Browns
emergency rental assistance bill which
would help renters make payments that
they've missed or future rent payments
so they can remain stable e housed and
landlords can get their payments failing
to put a safeguard in place to keep
people in their homes is most likely to
harm the most vulnerable Americans and
to harm communities of color it is
critical that we act now we cannot delay
any longer and with that I will turn
this over to Senator Van Hollen honey
it's all yours
thank you Thank You Senator Warren and
to leader Schumer thank you for all your
focus on people who are most at risk
right now in our country and largely
because of the lack of action we've seen
from Senate Senator McConnell and Senate
Republicans to Senator Warren thank you
for those comments and everything else
you're doing to address these issues as
both my colleagues have said the clock
is ticking the seconds are winding down
in two days the federal protections
blocking evictions will expire so what
does that mean for the millions of
Americans who are at home stretching to
make ends meet it means they're at risk
in fact millions of Americans are now at
risk of eviction
Maryland if you look around the country
this is a human catastrophe in the
making and the real of tragedy here is
it's a hundred percent avoidable if we
were to take action instead of action
Senator McConnell I listened to his
comments on the floor of the Senate the
other day he never mentioned
was over two months ago that Senator
Warren and I Senator Schumer and others
joined sherrod Brown in introducing the
emergency rental assistance and rental
market stabilization act a hundred
billion dollars legislation is in the
heroes act legislation is in the heroes
Act which also was passed more than two
months ago so here we are counting down
the minutes we should never have been at
this point where millions of American
families
seventy-five billion dollar homeowners
Assistance Fund to help homeowners pay
their mortgages and keep a roof over
their head
so assistance for homeowners and
assistance desperately needed for
renters that was two months ago
for God's sakes it is gross negligence
if we don't get this done now and help
our fellow Americans in need and
articulate comments we'll take questions
a few questions yes ma'am yes we just we
did not get into negotiation it was not
on their list it was on our list we have
a health crisis an economic crisis and a
crisis in our values bearing down upon
us with millions of people about to lose
their housing and all leader McConnell
wants to talk about is how to protect
giant corporations that tells us where
his values are and it also tells us how
wrong he is people across this country
in blue states and red states need
protection they need help and leader
McConnell needs to hear from all of them
I couldn't hear do you want to see Bill
text yes
well the devil is in the details they
don't tell us what they want what do
they want to do on unemployment
insurance how low how much are they
going to cut what are they gonna do for
schools no no you can't negotiate until
you have a detailed proposal and
particularly sorry and particularly in
light of the fact that they're not
unified we asked them yesterday is this
going to be something that the president
and the Senate Republicans support and
they were not sure well we can't first
negotiate with Senate Republicans and
then negotiate with the president that
doesn't make sense they don't they do
not have the view of the scope when
Mitch McConnell says a month ago when 20
million people are out of work 25
million people are out of work that
millions of businesses are going under
let's assess the situation that says
they're out of touch they're so in
lockstep to Donald Trump who is one of
the main reasons probably the main
reason the crisis is is worse as as bad
as it is and so so enthralled by the
business leadership which cares about
protecting themselves from all liability
and his bill there is way over the top
they're out of touch this is the
greatest economic crisis in 75 years the
greatest krell health crisis in a
hundred years McConnell goes to the
floor today doesn't mention them and
talks about the New York Times and
canceled culture all they want to do is
feed meat to the right-wing red meat
okay thank you every you want one more
go ahead yes you may
yes look it's very important for us to
keep it in this bill and it's one of our
very high priorities okay thanks
everybody